So, one way of doing this is to draw a square
and then turn a little bit to the right and then
draw another square. And then turn a little bit to the
right again and then draw another square. And keep doing that. Let's
build that. So, here's the piece of code that draws a
square. And after I've done that, what I want the turtle to
do is turn a little bit to the right. So, let
me add a piece of code that says brad.right, let's say by
ten degrees. Now, because I want these two statements to
happen over and over again, I will put them inside a loop. So let me do that. So
I'm going to add a for loop by saying for i in range, let's say this
loop runs four times. I'll add a colon and then put these two
things inside the loop. Let me save, and run, and see
what happens. Ah-ha, so here is the output. We've drawn two squares,
three squares and it should stop, there it is four squares. So all I have to
do now, is let the turtle keep going around the circle, which has 360 degrees.
So, this loop should run not four times, but 36
times instead. Let me save and
run that. All right. There it is, folks. A circle made out of squares. Now
I'm going to put some background music behind this
video and let you enjoy our final creation.
[MUSIC]